mes chers collègues donc nous recevons
Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
au sujet de la fin de vie
j'indique que c'est audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et qui sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande
cette audition s'inscrit dans le cadre
des travaux que nous menons sur la
question de la fin de vie bravo menés
par nos rapporteurs Christine Bonfanti
de sa Corinne Imbert et michelonnier ou
en plénière avec une table ronde sur les
enjeux philosophiques une autre sur les
anges juridique ainsi qu'une audition
conjointe des sociétés savantes par
ailleurs nous entendrons demain matin la
présidente du comité de gouvernance et
des quatre et des quatre membres de la
Convention citoyenne madame la ministre
nous savons que vous avez beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet qui se concerne
chacun d'entre nous nous attendons de
vous un éclairage sur les intentions du
Gouvernement en matière d'évolution du
droit et en matière de mise à
disposition réelle des soins palliatifs
pour nous concitoyens nous souhaitons
également que vous nous préciser
envisagé par le gouvernement pour
l'examen d'un projet de loi le cas
échéant je vous propose donc de
commencer cette audition commune par un
propos liminaire et ensuite nous
procéderons à un échange à partir des
questions de nos rapports et des autres
commissaires madame la ministre je vous
laisse la parole
madame la Présidente chère Catherine de
roche mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames
Imbert bonfantille meunier Mesdames et
Messieurs les commissaires aux affaires
sociales permettez-moi madame la
Présidente on prend en but de vous
remercier pour cette invitation je sais
la qualité des travaux que vous menez au
sein de cette commission des affaires
sociales j'y suis avec attention les
travaux de la mission de prospective que
vous avez lancé et me tient à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos hôtels
sur ce sujet essentiel de la fin de vie
comme vous le savez le président de la
République a souhaité le 13 septembre
dernier ouvrir un débat national sur la
fin de vie dans le prolongement de la
remise de la vie 139 du Comité national
consultatif d'éthique du CCNE cette
première étape c'est conclue par la
remise du rapport produits par les 184
citoyens réunis pendant quatre mois dans
le cadre de la convention citoyenne sur
la fin de vie et le président de la
République a le 3 avril fixé les
directions vers lesquelles il souhaitait
que nous avons collectivement
le travail que nous venons d'engager
dans cette deuxième phase repose sur
deux piliers il s'agit d'abord de
l'élaboration et la mise en oeuvre d'une
stratégie décennale de soins palliatifs
avec trois volets des soins palliatifs
la prise en charge de la douleur
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
tout ceci pour le terme de l'année 2023
c'est-à-dire fin décembre le président
de la République a également annoncé les
laboration d'un projet de loi d'ici la
fin de l'été sur laquelle je reviendrai
il me paraît utile de rappeler
brièvement les travaux que le
gouvernement a mené simultanément à ceux
de la convention citoyenne pendant la
première phase du débat national sur la
fin de vie
c'est ainsi une action qui a conjugué
les travaux de la convention citoyenne
sur la fin de vie la mission
d'évaluation de la loi classe leditive
par la commission des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée nationale qui s'est
inscrite dans le prolongement des
travaux d'information sur l'état des
lieux des soins palliatifs réalisés par
votre commission en septembre 2021 ce
sont également des travaux d'évaluation
de la politique de développement des
soins palliatifs par la Cour des comptes
dont la remise du rapport est prévue
pour la fin juin 2023
j'ai souhaité articuler nos travaux
autour de trois volets suivants pour une
mise en perspective des enjeux
identifiés autour de la fin de vie dans
notre pays sur la liberté de choisir sa
femme vie quelle réponse apportée à la
question posée par le CCNE dans son avis
139 de septembre 2022 un état des lieux
et des modalités de développement des
soins palliatifs avec les enjeux
d'égalité d'accès de formation des
professionnels de santé d'information de
nos concitoyens comme les directives
anticipées pour ne citer que cela le
sujet essentiel de l'accompagnement de
la fin de vie et du deuil avec notamment
la place et le rôle des aidants nous
avons tous en mémoire des situations
personnelles dramatiques durant la crise
covid nous menons un travail en ce sens
je souhaiterais d'abord vous présenter
la méthode qui a été la mienne depuis le
mois d'octobre dernier avant de revenir
sur les premiers enseignements qu'il est
possible d'en tirer et d'esquisser
quelques pistes pour la suite le
Gouvernement a souhaité engager les
travaux en cours de concertation en nous
appuyant sur les travaux d'évaluation
rendus par différentes instances sans
prétendre à l'exhaustivité je pense au
rapport IGAS sur la mort à l'hôpital de
2009 sur le registre national et
directive anticipé de 2015 sur les soins
palliatifs et la fin de vie à domicile
en 2017 il s'agit aussi des travaux
d'évaluation parlementaires de la loi du
2 février 2016 les travaux d'évaluation
du plan 2015-2017 sur les soins
palliatifs et d'accompagnement de la fin
de vie l'évaluation des dispositifs
spécialisés de prise en charge des
maladies neurogédinarratives en 2022
aussi le rapport sur les aidants et les
solutions de répit 2023 mais aussi sur
les avis du CCNE 2018 et 2022
j'ai souhaité en parallèle une
accélération du déploiement de mesure du
cinquième plan de développement des
soins palliatifs et particulièrement la
rénovation de la circulaire du 25 mars
2008 relative à l'organisation des soins
palliatifs avec en corollaire un
ajustement des moyens alloués aussi en
palatifs pédiatriques la publication de
la nouvelle instruction est imminente je
crois que ça devrait être dans les jours
prochains j'ai mené dans le cadre de
cette première étape de réflexion sur la
fin de très nombreuses auditions et
visites
plus de 80 entretiens avec les
principales parties prenantes à Paris et
sur le terrain des visites en hexagone
et en Outremer une quinzaine
d'établissements ou structures
Intervenant à domicile établissements de
santé des établissements médico-sociaux
des échanges avec près de 150 personnes
professionnelles de santé élus autorité
religieuse obédience maçonniques
responsable associatif personnalité des
arts et des lettres des déplacements
d'études pour échanger avec les
autorités experts internationaux de pays
ayant légalisé l'aide active à mourir
plus ou moins récemment ou ayant
interrompu le processus
je suis allé comme certains le savent
déjà ensuite en Italie en Belgique au
Royaume-Uni en Espagne et en Europe j'ai
souhaité également l'installation et
l'animation de deux groupes de travail
un groupe contact parlementaire certains
d'entre vous ici y ont participé
transpartisans et bicaméral et un groupe
professionnel de santé les membres de
ces deux groupes ont été réunis de
manière spécifique pour une
sensibilisation et une appropriation des
travaux menés mais aussi associé à
l'occasion d'ateliers thématiques pour
réfléchir à des propositions conjointes
sur l'anticipation et la culture
paliative l'accompagnement du deuil et
des aidants les réflexions éthiques et
les dispositifs d'aide actifs à mourir
j'ai souhaité également saisir France
assaut santé pour recueillir les avis
des structures concernées avis qui
doivent mettre remis très prochainement
nous avons réalisé une saisine de la
Conférence nationale de santé pour
mesurer les conditions favorisant la
relation partenariale entre usagers et
professionnels du système de santé j'ai
souhaité également connaître leur
recommandation sur les conditions
nécessaires à l'engagement dans la durée
des instances de démocratie en santé
nationale et territoriale CNS CRSA cts
dans le suivi des politiques de santé
dans le domaine de la fin de vie
en parallèle une mission a été confiée à
un groupe d'initiés aux questions de fin
de vie écrivain sociologue professionnel
de santé juriste réunis autour des
récorsenna afin de travailler sur le
champ lexical de la fin de vie donc
questionner le sens pour nos concitoyens
et les usages par les Français chargés
de rédiger un lexique exploratoire à
destination d'un large public dont les
contributions finales seront adressées
d'ici la fin juillet
janvier en premier enseignement qu'il
nous est possible de retirer de ces
travaux de réflexion et d'évaluation
les travaux d'évaluation de la loi
classe leetti et notamment ceux de la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale ont souligné des
difficultés persistantes de mise en
oeuvre de différentes mesures
si cette loi à sans conteste permet
d'impulser une nouvelle dynamique à la
prise en charge de la fin de vie et à la
diffusion de la culture palliative en
France avec par exemple des mesures
permettant une meilleure prise en charge
de la souffrance et en clarifiant
l'usage de la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès en phase
terminale nous constatons néanmoins la
nécessité de renforcer les étapes et le
caractère collégial du processus
décisionnel conduisant à l'arrêt des
traitements une mauvaise appréciation de
l'impact de l'arrêt de l'hydratation et
de l'alimentation une insuffisance de
formation des différentes sédation
des populations malidentifiées les
mineurs certains cancers
les questions liées à la fin de vie sont
parmi les plus complexes auxquelles les
professionnels de santé et le
législateur sont confrontés dans le
domaine de la santé la loi du 2 février
2016 a constitué une avancée très
importante par rapport à la loi de 2005
et permet de répondre à l'immense
majorité des situations de fin de vie
beaucoup de chemins restent néanmoins à
parcourir pour résorber le décalage
entre la loi et la pratique
quel que soit la législation et le souci
d'assurer sa mise en oeuvre rigoureuse
sur le terrain il n'y a pas de bonne
mort de mort zéro défaut ni de bonnes
solutions à la mort il faut garder à
l'esprit le caractère profondément
singulier douloureux et complexe de
chaque situation de fin de vie
cependant tel que le soulignait le
comblait le Conseil consultatif national
d'éthique en 2018 les questions éthiques
ne seront jamais résolues par la loi il
existe une voie pour une consultation
éthique d'une aide active à mourir à
certaines consignes avec lesquelles il
est inacceptable de transiger dans son
avis 139 rendu le 13 septembre 2022 le
CCNE trace un nouvel équilibre entre
autonomie et solidarité pour modifier le
cadre actuel de la fin de vie en France
les travaux réalisés par la Convention
citoyenne fin de vie ont permis de
souligner l'évolution de la société
française à cet égard c'est 184
conventionnelles ont incarné par leur
représentativité la société française
avec la recherche permanente d'une
expression légitime ils ont réalisé un
véritable exercice de démocratie
participative ils ont respecté les avis
différents voire divergents qui
s'exprimaient une des membres de cette
convention disait hier merci au 75% des
favorables de nous avoir laissé 50% du
temps de parole et 50% du contenu du
rapport je trouve la très seule la
positif et ce lundi aussi à quel point
sur un sujet de société tel que celui-ci
qui nous concerne tous la réflexion et
l'intelligence collective peuvent bâtir
aboutir à des propositions consensuelles
les travaux de la convention citoyenne
ont confirmé l'orientation favorable de
la société française à la mise en place
d'une aide active à mourir ainsi la
profondeur de l'orientation de la
société française vers une évolution de
la loi visant à l'agir les droits des
malades sur leur fin de vie cette il
confirmé au-delà de la perception du lég
islateur qui en avait toutefois soutenu
l'expression via différentes
propositions de loi 5 initiés ces
dernières années entre 2017 et 2023
je reviens la deuxième phase des travaux
lancés par le chef de l'État le 3 avril
le dernier les conclusions des travaux
de la convention citoyenne constituent
un support important pour définir les
contours du futur mudel desactives à
mourir le chef de l'État a identifié
certaines limites soulignant notamment
la stricte ouverture de l'aide active à
mourir aux personnes majeures dont le
pronostic vital serait engagé à moyen
terme disposant de leur plein
discernement nous disposons d'un
important matériel pour travailler
beaucoup de production ont été livrées
ces derniers mois qui a pu ses travaux
et les autres et les vôtres viendront
les compléter il est nécessaire de
trouver un équilibre entre une ouverture
d'un nouveau droit pour les Français et
les préoccupations légitimes des
professionnels
vous le savez il ressort de mes
différents déplacements à l'étranger
qu'aucun modèle n'est duplicable in
extenso dans notre pays aussi il semble
indispensable pour construire ce modèle
français de la fin de vie d'avancer avec
les soignants et l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et du milieu de
cause sociale qui sont au coeur de
l'accompagnement des personnes en fin de
vie particulièrement lorsqu'elle souffre
des conséquences d'une maladie incurable
car la bienveillance est d'abord dans la
préservation de l'humain jusque la mort
elle débute bien en amont et repose sur
celles et ceux qui sont autour de la
personne qui veut mourir professionnel
et proches
le modèle français de la fin de vie
devra ainsi reposer sur au moins trois
volets sur lequel nous avons initié les
travaux le développement des soins
palliatifs dans le cadre d'un plan
décennal en identifiant les mesures qui
relèvent du législatif l'ouverture d'un
nouveau droit vers une aide active à
mourir sous conditions et une attention
renforcée à la protection des personnes
et aux droits des patients la loi devra
évidemment cadrer les choses
identifier les critères d'entrée dans le
parcours poser des conditions très
précises et principes à respecter
quelqu'un tel qu'indiqué par le
Président de la République le 3 avril à
cet égard l'analyse des dispositifs mis
en place dans les pays étrangers
critères délégitibilité encadrement et
traçabilité tout au long de la procédure
réalisée par le gouvernement pendant la
phase de concertation a permis
d'identifier les glissements potentiels
et les conditions pour les prévenir
comme l'ont indiqué le chef de l'État la
première ministre ce projet de loi nous
le co-construirons avec les
parlementaires en mobilisant la
connaissance et l'expérience des
soignants
concernant le plan décennale sur lequel
le gouvernement souhaite avancer en
parallèle les travaux d'élaboration du
futur projet de loi j'ai installé jeudi
dernier l'instance de réflexion
stratégique dont les experts et
personnes qualifiées ont sous la
houlette du professeur Franck Chauvin et
le concours de l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales engager les travaux
visant à élaborer différents scénarios
pour que nous soyons en mesure
d'apporter des réponses concrètes à nos
concitoyens dont la fin de vie constitue
un moment de grandes fragilité et
d'apporter un soutien à leurs proches
des dents y compris autour du deuil ce
plan concernera également la prise en
charge de la douleur sans considération
à l'âge et donc avec une attention aux
mineurs aussi tout le monde
conventionnel soignant parlementaire
institution s'accorde sur le nécessaire
renforcement des soins palliatifs y
compris à domicile le développement de
l'anticipation et de la culture
palliative et de l'accompagnement du
deuil
le rapport de la mission d'évaluation
par la commission des affaires sociales
de la loi du 2 février 2016 souligne
qu'il faut poursuivre et accélérer la
mise en place des mesures prévues et en
particulier s'agissant de la formation
des professionnels à la prise en charge
de la douleur à l'écoute du patient et
au respect des volontés en termes
d'arrêt des thérapeutique il reste
beaucoup à faire pour que les nouveaux
droits qui avaient été apportés par
cette loi soit mieux et plus largement
appliqué c'est pourquoi il nous faut
travailler à promouvoir une approche
transversale et ouverte des soins
palliatifs pour favoriser la propriation
par chacun de cette prise en charge
spécifique pour assurer une intégration
palliative dans notre pays c'est ce que
j'ai souhaité engager avec la rénovation
de la circulaire organisant l'offre de
soins qui datait de 2008
merci madame la ministre qui commence
dans les rapporteurs vous allez Michel
et oui je veux bien j'ai un impératif
après pour la commission des affaires
sociales dans la foulée donc merci merci
donc Madame la Ministre oui c'est
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
concertation vous avez développé tout ce
que vous avez mis en place au départ
avec votre collègue Olivier Véran qui
apparemment s'est arrêté de s'intéresser
au sujet enfin vous allez nous dire et
puis j'ai vu aussi que
enfin c'était vous qui étiez donc la
responsabilise responsabilisée sur cette
texte puisque votre collègue le ministre
de la Santé avait je pense quelques
réserves réticences dans les trois
volets que vous abordez donc les soins
palliatifs
la protection des soignants je pense
qu'il y aura largement consensus
là-dessus restera donc active à mourir
au Sénat c'est un peu la même chose
puisque je t'ai rapporté d'une
proposition de loi de ma collègue du
groupe socialiste psychologiste et
républicains qui n'avaient pas eu la vie
favorable du Sénat bloquant surtout que
c'était l'article premier sur les dates
qui va mourir mais on disait assistance
aux suicide et euthanasie donc je
comprends
l'importance des mots des vocables à
terminologie enfin vous l'avez dit et le
travail engagé par
Eric Orsenna mais au-delà au-delà des
mots j'aimerais savoir jusqu'où ce texte
pourra être envisagé enfin est-ce que
vous êtes là-dessus
engagée est-ce que le Président de la
République a été plus précis que cela
dans sa demande
merci je vais mieux répondre donc au fur
et à mesure
sur la volonté du Président de la
République lorsque le président de la
République dit il faut un projet de loi
sur l'aide active à mourir c'est bien la
volonté d'introduire ce nouveau droit
dans la loi
puisque je vous l'ai dit les travaux de
co-construction vont démarrer la semaine
prochaine à la fois à l'écoute des
soignants à la fois avec les
parlementaires je ne vais pas préjugé de
ce vers quoi nous irons pour la j'allais
dire technique même si je n'aime pas
trop ce terme de la mise en place de la
mourir il s'agira-t-il de l'euthanasie
s'agira-t-il du suicide assisté c'est
les travaux que nous menons
[Musique]
voilà le principe c'est bien que la loi
va ouvrir ce nouveau droit le travail de
co-construction nous amènera à choisir
le chemin pour y arriver mais la volonté
du Président de la République sur le
projet de loi qui devra être présenté
avant la fin de l'été donc avant le 21
septembre c'est bien d'ouvrir ce nouveau
droit sous certaines critères
d'égibilité pour le coup là ça a été
très clair pas les mineurs pronostic
vital engagés à moyen terme et
discernement les travaux que nous devons
mener et de savoir si vers quel
modalités nous nous orientons voilà mais
c'est bien l'ouverture du nouveau droit
de ce nouveau droit sur une aide active
à mourir qui a été exprimée par le
Président de la République
la possibilité
d'une nouvelle loi et de
pénaliser l'euthanasie
ne craignez-vous pas la difficulté de
maîtriser les conséquences d'une telle
ouverture puisque si on regarde des
exemples étrangers et les parents de
constater soit un élargissement tôt ou
tard des critères
soit une augmentation du nombre de
suicides alors que finalement on
s'attendait plutôt aller faire baisser
et puis comme nous l'avons constaté
divers pays quelques dérives qui sont
souvent difficiles à contrôler comme au
Canada par exemple
je l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire
nous avons vraiment souhaité aller à
l'étranger justement pour voir dans les
pays qui avait légiféré depuis longtemps
comme la Belgique qui a légiférer depuis
20 ans
en Espagne qui a fait le même choix que
la Belgique qui a fait le choix de
l'euthanasie qui a légiféré depuis trois
ans
quels étaient les j'allais dire à la
fois le nombre de personnes qui avaient
accès à l'euthanasie en Belgique
pourquoi en Espagne après l'application
de la loi il y avait aussi peu de cas
c'était l'objet de nos déplacements sur
l'élargissement des critères
très peu de pays ont augmenté leur
critères la Belgique a légiférer 10 ans
après sur l'ouverture au mineur 10 ans
après
ça fait quelques remous puisque il y a
des il y a des critères j'ai aussi en
Belgique écouté et c'était important de
pouvoir écouter aussi les professionnels
qui souhaitaient à la base que la loi
n'évolue pas et qui nous ont mis en
garde contre certains glissements donc
on a aussi entendu entendu
ces professionnels pendant un très long
moment
je suis allé aussi en Orgon voir comment
fonctionnait le modèle aurait donné le
modèle aurait donné
pour comprendre comment eux il y a 25
ans avaient légiféré pourquoi il avait
fait ce choix de suicide assister il y a
25 ans et pourquoi pas un autre
et aussi écouter et parler avec les
législateurs
américains de savoir les questions qu'il
se posent pour faire évoluer la loi ils
sont en train de se poser la question du
moyen terme par exemple
c'est quelque chose sur lequel ils sont
en train de en train de réfléchir
on voit bien que voilà les questions se
posent dans certains pays après l'idée
aussi d'être allé voir ailleurs c'est de
pouvoir collecter tous les critères
d'éligibilité et en fonction des
glissements qui nous ont été j'allais
dire rapportés dans certains pays de
pouvoir éviter ces glissements au fur et
à mesure du temps c'était bien là le
sens de ces visites et elles ont été
d'ailleurs très instructives à cet égard
parce que même parfois nos questions ont
interrogé même les pays dans lesquels on
a posé ces questions je prends la
question du modèle origoné j'ai demandé
le devenir du petit flacon par exemple
c'est peut-être le prisme du pharmacien
qui veut gérer la Corée du corps
bah voilà et ils ont été ils ont été ils
ont été très surpris par ma question moi
j'étais surprise qui soit surpris mais
ils ont été très surpris par ma question
et en fait mais en fait non non mais en
fait la problématique c'est que pour eux
et on voit bien quand je dis que aucun
modèle
duplicable inextenso c'est parce qu'on
n'a pas la même culture et pour eux ça
pose pas de question ils ont des armes
chez eux ils ont des armes chez eux donc
la question du flacon pour eux ne se
pose pas
non non mais c'est quand même assez ça a
été non mais donc on voit bien que
culturellement on n'a pas les mêmes on
n'a pas les mêmes questions on n'a pas
les mêmes interrogations et donc c'était
intéressant
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la Ministre effectivement c'était
c'était une question pour sortir un
petit peu des questions qui vous ont été
soumises
pourquoi aucun modèle et duplicable dans
notre pays alors on vient d'évoquer
l'Orégon mais pourquoi les autres
modèles ne sont pas duplicables en
France
juste pour
essayer de comprendre et surtout de voir
peut-être certaines contradictions dans
la réflexion qui nous est soumise vous
nous avez dit la loi 2016 c'est une
avancée très importante tout le monde
connaît que elle n'est pas assez connue
pas assez enseignée pas assez appliqué
et donc il y a un décalage et vous
l'avez dit entre la loi et la pratique
et pour autant
nous réfléchissons à légiférer à nouveau
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas se dire et bien
la loi c'est une avancée importante on
la salue à nouveau et pourquoi ne pas se
dire on comment on va faire qu'elle soit
mieux appliquée c'est une une question
je reprends vos propos les questions
éthiques ne seront jamais résolues par
la loi
et derrière le bien mourir je sais pas
si on peut bien mourir mais enfin bon
sur la la mourir dans la dignité pour
représenter pour reprendre une
expression qui est souvent employée
comment la loi va améliorer les choses
est-ce que la loi va pouvoir améliorer
les choses je ne sais pas
comment ça pourra ça pourrait être senti
ensuite et puis peut-être parce que vous
avez beaucoup parlé je vous en remercie
des soins palliatifs
qu'est-ce qu'il y a avancé depuis 18
mois depuis l'annonce du 5e plan
consacré aux soins palliatifs
voilà est-ce qu'il y a eu est-ce qu'il y
a eu des avancées et qu'est-ce que le
texte ne fera pas et est-ce que
avec les débats parlementaires
vous craignez peut-être que de certaines
choses vous échappent dans la loi ou pas
je vous remercie
d'abord je vais répondre à la dernière
question c'est le principe du débat
parlementaire
moi je ne crains pas que des choses
échappent ou pas ça s'appelle la
démocratie et que chacun doit pouvoir
exprimer ses idées sur un sujet aussi
difficile que celui-là qui est un vrai
sujet de société pour le coup un sujet
complètement trans partisan je pense que
nous avons aussi
collectivement
l'opportunité de montrer à nos
concitoyens que sur ces sujets de
société nous sommes capables de débattre
en nous écoutant et en nous respectant
je dois dire que les 6 à 8 mois de
travaux que je viens de faire sur ce
sujet montre à quel point d'abord la
convention citoyenne a ouvert la voie
les débats que j'ai pu faire en
circonscription dans vos
circonscriptions enfin
franchement j'en ai fait beaucoup j'en
ai même fait un dans une église à
l'invitation d'un évêque
et ben je peux vous assurer que montre à
quel point nos concitoyens ils ont envie
de parler de ce sujet
et c'est plutôt assez surprenant parce
que en fait il pose pas de question ils
font des témoignages qui engendrent un
contre témoignage qui engendre un contre
témoignage et la conversation se fait
comme ça mais ils ont très envie d'en
parler donc concitoyens vraiment et ils
sont pas d'accord mais ils écoutent et
c'est assez surprenant donc moi je suis
pas inquiète sur voilà l'idée c'est de
d'apporter un texte c'est un projet de
loi c'est le gouvernement qui présentera
le texte on le construira avec les
lignes fixées par le gouvernement mais
on le construira avec les parlementaires
et après le texte vivra son parcours
parlementaire donc moi pour là-dessus
j'ai pas de problème et je trouve l'idée
intéressante puisqu'on a commencé à
travailler ensemble de construire de
continuer à construire ensemble après
sur les trois sur les trois avis
pourquoi la loi place léonity ne
suffirait pas d'ailleurs c'est l'avis du
CCNE qui le dit c'est pour ça que le
Président de la République il a souhaité
engager les débats c'est le CCNE
dont la vie du CCNE monsieur clès
monsieur Claisse était était
partisan de ce nouvel avis qui dit que
la loi classe leetti ne répond pas à
toutes les situations et là on passe on
sort du très court terme auquel
la loi peut être le type peut répondre
elle ne répond pas parce que mal
appliquée parce que pas connu parce que
mal appliqué mais là on est plutôt sur
le moyen terme et la loi classe Leonetti
ne peut pas répondre au moyen terme ça
c'est une autre question
là on est sur la loi c'est l'ouverture
d'un nouveau droit elle ne retirer rien
à personne
elle ouvre un nouveau droit dont il nous
faut devenir les modalités la loi classe
leeting ne pourra jamais répondre à la
maladie de Charcot par exemple qui est
celle sur lequel on voit bien les
questions les questions se posent les
questions se posent je cite
volontairement il y a des seins la
maladie de Charcot je le fais exprès
voilà
voilà et la troisième et la troisième
question la troisième le troisième axe
de votre question c'était sur les soins
palliatifs la volonté du Président de la
République a été très claire dès le 13
septembre c'est il nous faut aussi de
façon parallèle tirer les conséquences
de ce pourquoi
après chaque plan quinquennale on se
posait toujours les mêmes questions
pourquoi encore vain département à
l'heure actuelle en France n'ont pas
d'unité de soins palliatifs pourquoi et
donc nous avons fait le choix de nous
calquer sur le modèle de l'Inca
c'est-à-dire partir sur une stratégie à
long terme pour se dire posons-nous les
bases et donnons-nous des perspectives
de travail un peu différente mais à long
terme nous pensons que c'est par ce
moyen que nous allons pouvoir réussir à
apporter à apporter des réponses
moi je vais avant de passer la parole au
commissaire j'avais une question ce
serait une procédure accélérée
alors là vous me posez une question là à
l'heure actuelle ou alors on n'a pas
commencé à écrire le projet de loi je
crois pas que sur ce sujet là il y a de
procédure accélérée possible c'est très
bien parce que c'était comme ça mais je
souhaite enfin je souhaite
je souhaite que il faut que ce soit en
effet un temps de réflexion très long
non non j'ai volontairement tout à
l'heure rappelé tous les travaux qui
avaient déjà été fait voilà moi je vais
pas préjugé de ce que décidera
accessoirement l'Assemblée nationale ni
le Sénat chacun chacun ses
responsabilités mais mais enfin on peut
aussi se dire que ces travaux
nécessitent du temps de la réflexion
mais des échanges mais je dois aussi
pouvoir dire qu'on ne part pas de nulle
part que il y a déjà eu beaucoup de
travaux qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'échanges
mais il faudra prendre le temps et on
prendra le temps
je ne préjugais pas de ce que décideront
les présidents des deux chambres c'est
certainement pas le rôle du gouvernement
[Musique]
ensuite Daniel Chassain Laurent Bourgoin
n'a mis l'envers toutes les questions
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la Ministre effectivement vous avez mené
des travaux de concertation et moi je
mange je m'en réjouis j'ai une question
c'est une question on l'a déjà dit si
qui interroge l'intime et qui transcende
effectivement tous les partis politiques
et puis on évolue aussi au gré des
échanges et des rencontres qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir
donc j'entends les trois volets je
trouve que c'est important que c'est
intéressant et bien souvent enfin je
rejoins un peu ce que mes collègues ont
dit c'est à dire on a tendance à opposer
un peu les choses c'est-à-dire que
la loi classe Léonetti est une loi
importante mais elle est très peu connue
elle est elle est très peu appliquée
mais on peut pas seulement faire ce
constat pour pour ne pas essayer essayer
d'aller plus loin et et mais moi
j'aimerais savoir quand même quelle
mesure vous comptez parallèlement ou en
même temps le en même temps en plus en
même temps mettre en place pour que
cette loi soit mieux connue mieux
appliquée de même je trouve qu'on peut
pas
déconnecter des soins palliatifs or on
peut à partir du moment où on parle des
soins palliatifs il est question de
moyens humains de moyens financiers et
malgré les cinq plans qui ont été mis
quand même en neuf ce qui n'est pas rien
5 plans ça veut dire un travail une
réflexion etc on voit bien que l'argent
qui a été
débloqué qui est autour de 170 millions
d'euros et largement insuffisant et
entraîne en fait des inégalités très
importantes par rapport à l'accès à ces
soins donc qu'est-ce que vous comptez
mettre en place pour mener je dirais
parce qu'il faut qu'on soit bien sur nos
deux pieds quoi à la fois sur les les
soins palliatifs et à la fois pour cet
accompagnement cette ouverture d'un
nouveau droit et de fait mon autre
question c'est de dire comment vous
envisagez de faire en sorte que la
culture des soins palliatifs soit mieux
prise en compte au niveau de la
formation et notamment de la formation
universitaire parce que je pense que
c'est aussi là que ça fait défaut je
vous remercie Daniel Chassin merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
ministre et comme ça vient d'être dit on
voit que vous avez beaucoup travaillé
d'audition et de et de visites n'avait
indiqué que la majorité l'immense
majorité des prises en charge de fin de
vie étaient satisfaisant et qui failli
développer effectivement les soins
palliatifs et la formation de la douleur
ça se sûrement et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose de très pourtant est-ce
que ça
ce projet
de renforcer les soins palliatifs est-ce
que c'est pas quelque chose
effectivement qui pourrait donner
satisfaction par rapport à la loi
Léonetti classe qui donne complètement
satisfaction
vous avez dit également que
ça s'adressait à des morts à moyen terme
mort à moyen terme je sais pas trop ce
que ça veut dire si vous voulez
disposant discernement vous savez en
EHPAD quand on voit les gens à moyen
terme ça veut dire un an deux ans voilà
donc ça veut ça veut absolument rien
dire je voudrais rappeler que le
professeur Théo Bauer qui a été
professeur d'éthique qui est professeur
d'éthique aux Pays-Bas indique que en
2002 il y avait 1800 personnes
qui
ont pratiquait le l'euthanasie et le
suicide donc c'était 90% des malades qui
étaient en phase terminale de cancer et
actuellement il estime que on est à 7600
c'est-à-dire 4 fois plus et donc
et donc si vous voulez on a on a
multiplié par 4 et comme ça a été dit
aussi tout à l'heure et ben il y a une
dérive et que même si
on veut essayer de faire le maximum pour
que ça ne dérive pas finalement il dit
ça dérive et si on avait eu les soins
palliatifs en 2002 et bien il y aurait
jamais eu le vote pour l'euthanasie ou
les
ou le suicide assisté donc je voudrais
rappeler aussi que
le nombre de malades qui demandent la
mort
quand ils sont vraiment malades ils
demandent à guérir il demande pas la
mort enfin on en a très rarement vu qui
demande la mort il demande à guérir et
les personnes qui travaillent aussi dans
les soins palliatifs où on EHPAD 80% de
80% d'entre eux bien ne souhaiterait
plus travailler dans les services si on
arrivait avec les soins palliatifs à
changer de paradis que dit donc le
professeur Leonetti c'est-à-dire
donner la mort et non pas de soigner
donc la deuxième question que je voulais
poser ne pensez-vous pas que malgré les
garde-fous on va évoluer si vous voulez
comme dans les Pays-Bas à dériver et
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
pourrait très grave pour moi
peut-être je vais faire une synthèse
interventions précédentes par rapport à
ce même palliatifs avec deux questions
directes madame la ministre par rapport
aux annonces que vous venez de faire à
quelle échéance pensez-vous que chaque
département pourra disposer de Dead
palliatifs et l'unité d'unité et avec
à quelque chose précise dans les années
avant de dire à moyen terme et
avec quel budget parce que gouverner
c'est prévoir et il fera faire des choix
des choix budgétaires donc
quel financement vous trouverez la
deuxième question c'est c'est plus
question juridique voir philosophique
par rapport au projet de loi chacun
votera son âme inconscience je crois que
par rapport à lire des fois des cas
particuliers qu'on a pu connaître dans
nos familles ou dans nos amis
comment arriver madame aministre à une
loi qui qui ne peut être que générale
qu'elle soit juste et efficace pour
résoudre chaque carte chaque cas
particulier
très bien madame la ministre je laisse
ensuite on aura un ami long et vernis
je vais me permettre tout d'abord de
répondre tout de suite à Monsieur
Chassin j'ai pas dit que la mort engagé
à moyen terme le pronostic vital
pronostic vigal engagé à moyen terme
c'est bien l'objet des travaux qu'on
mène avec les soignants c'est de définir
le moyen terme je rappelle qu'on aurait
donc le moyen terme c'est 6 mois donc
ils sont en train de se poser la
question sur quel est le moyen terme
je vais répondre à la question sur le le
modèle duplicable j'ai pas répondu tout
à l'heure
madame la sénatrice Imbert pourquoi j'en
avais déduit que il y avait pas de
modèle duplicable pourquoi d'abord parce
que on n'a pas la même culture là c'est
un vrai sujet parce que ensuite il y a
pas de loi ensuite c'est le principe
c'est tout ce qui n'est pas interdit est
autorisé
parce qu'en Italie il n'y a pas de loi
non plus ils sont partis sur le concept
de la désobéissance civile
donc ça fait déjà beaucoup de beaucoup
de choses parce que en Belgique
notamment sur le l'enjeu de la
traçabilité par exemple du process moi
je tiens à ce qu'il y a une traçabilité
de A à Z d'abord ça nous permettra
d'évaluer beaucoup plus facilement quand
on se posera la question l'évaluation ce
qui n'est pas été possible de faire sur
la loi classic on n'est pas capable en
France de dire combien de sédation
profondes continue on était pratiqués on
ne sait pas on peut pas il y a pas de de
traçabilité je pense que sur le plan
éthique et sur le plan juridique ça
permet de sécuriser les professionnels
de savoir que tout a été bien donc il
n'y a pas de modèle duplicat pour
beaucoup de raisons parce que nos
systèmes politiques ne sont pas les
mêmes aussi voilà donc ça fait beaucoup
parce que notre système de soins n'est
pas le même parce que l'antériorité des
soins palliatifs n'est pas la même dans
tous les pays en Suisse par exemple les
soins palliatifs sont arrivés après le
suicide assisté voilà donc ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup de raisons pour se
dire que par contre dans chacun des pays
il y a quelque chose d'intéressant à
prendre pour essayer de construire une
loi qui fasse la synthèse de tout ça sur
les soins palliatifs il faut être très
clair
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut avancer
tout le monde tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut avancer le constat
que nous avons fait et je le je l'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire tout à l'heure
c'est que au bout des plans quinquennaux
on n'a pas réussi
on n'a pas réussi à ce que la totalité
des départements français soit couvert
alors je vais le préciser en unité de
soins palliatif ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas des listes enfin
palliatifs dans tous les départements
faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
parce que c'est important voilà et que
et que pourquoi il y a pas d'unité de
son palliatifs parce que parfois
certains hôpitaux ont fait le choix on
fait le choix alors qu'ils avaient les
moyens de le développer de faire
d'autres choix c'est à dire que la
problématique c'est qu'en unité de son
palliatifs pour certains hôpitaux c'est
que statistiquement on y décède
et donc fallait le faire le choix
d'investir pour accompagner vers
vers la mort et que certains préférait
investir dans d'autres domaines plus
curatifs parce qu'en France parce qu'en
France on a la culture du curatif et que
ne pas réussir à soigner ses vécu comme
certains par un échec et que le
palliatif est peut-être vécu comme un
échec et donc c'est les l'enjeu c'est de
développer cette culture palliative
cette anticipation palliative et donc
pour ça il faut former et il faut former
des études de médecine ce qui n'est pas
le cas ce qui n'est pas le cas dans les
études initiales de médecine il n'y a
pas de formation sur les soins
palliatifs l'enjeu majeur c'est bien de
former les médecins de former les
professionnels aussi infirmiers et les
aides-soignantes pour développer cette
culture palliative l'enjeu de la
formation notamment dans les EHPAD des
infirmières et des aides soignantes sur
la culture palliative et pour moi
majeure pour pouvoir maintenir les
personnes âgées en accompagnement en
soins palliatifs en EHPAD le plus
longtemps possible donc
[Musique]
et tous les professionnels et l'enjeu
autour des soins palliatifs c'est bien
l'enjeu du développement à domicile
parce que certes il nous faut des unités
de soins palliatifs dans tous les
départements et puisque vous m'avez
demandé une date
nous essaierons de faire en sorte que à
la fin 2024 à la fin 2024 les vins
départements français qui n'ont pas
actuellement d'unités sont palliatifs en
une et puis il y a un enjeu dont on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé c'est l'enjeu des
unités de soins palliatifs pédiatriques
en France la prise en charge de la
douleur chez les enfants et des sons
palliatifs n'est pas du tout développé
donc là aussi nous allons réfléchir même
s'il y a des unités des équipes
régionales de soins palliatifs
pédiatriques nous allons essayer de
développer et heureusement Il en faut
beaucoup moins pour les adultes parce
que parce que heureusement pour les
enfants il y a moins de décès chez les
enfants que chez les adultes nous allons
essayer de développer un schéma avec je
sais pas si ce sera 4 5 ou 6 unités ne
sont pas négatifs pédiatrique mais je
nous allons essayer de développer un
schéma pour développer ces unités pour
prendre en charge les cas les plus
complexes parce qu'il y a des enfants
qui ont besoin d'être pris en charge et
donc ça ce sera quelque chose de nouveau
nous allons vraiment travailler sur la
filière avec une gradation l'unité de
soins palliatifs pédiatrique c'est les
cas complexes le domicile
et travailler sur l'hospitalisation de
jour
en soi palliatifs ça nous permet
d'anticiper la prise en charge à la fois
de la douleur mais aussi l'anticipation
palliative c'est quelque chose
d'important dans la gradation de la
prise en charge voilà je crois avoir
répondu à la majorité des questions et
sur les soins palliatifs et je veux
revenir dans le schéma je pense qu'il
faut pas opposer l'un à l'autre nous
avons réussi dans les débats à ne pas
opposer les soins palliatifs et le
développement nécessaire des soins
palliatifs à l'ouverture de ce nouveau
droit je le redis l'un ne retirer rien
ne retirent rien à l'autre et je pense
que là aussi où il faut avancer et pour
le coup les visites nombreuses que j'ai
faites partout dans le
schéma qui nous amènera à la décision
s'assurer que la proposition de passage
en soins palliatifs étaient faites à une
personne qui souhaiterait qui serait
éligible et qui souhaiterait bénéficier
de l'aide à qui va mourir me paraît
nécessaire me paraît nécessaire
merci Madame merci Madame Nice pour
l'ensemble de ces explications moi quand
la loi Léonetti est arrivée on a tous
tous trouvé que c'était un grand progrès
et puis on a essayé de mettre en
application et quand la loi de classe
Léonetti est arrivée on a tous dit la
même chose elle arrive trop tôt on n'a
pas eu le temps de mettre en application
l'ensemble de la loi léonétique pourquoi
faire ses propositions supplémentaires
mais quand je regarde bien le délai
entre la loi ne dit et la loi classique
et plus long que le délai entre la loi
christionity et les propositions doigts
faites sur sur l'aide activa mourir donc
je me demande si comme on constate qu'il
n'y a pas eu une mise en application
totale de la loi classique si on n'a pas
laissé de délai suffisant pour la mettre
en application totale ça c'est juste une
question que je me pose à moi-même n'est
pas obligé d'y répondre par contre je me
pose deux autres questions
pour parler un d'aide active à mourir
qui est actif et qui doit être actif
dans l'aide à mourir
et puis vous parlez d'un droit ce droit
s’exerce par qui et il s'impose à qui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je pense que pas mal de choses
ont été répondues
il est évident qu'il faut pas opposer
les soins palliatifs et active à mourir
et la vie du CCNE alors il ouvre une
voie certes mais il met quand même une
chronologie à la fin il dit que les
datives à mourir à la limite pourquoi
pas parce que même si les soins
palliatifs étaient seront tout point du
territoire parfait il y aura toujours
une petite niche pour laquelle l'aide
d'active va mourir serait nécessaire
pour autant il instaure dans son avis
une forme de chronologie en disant
est-ce qu'il serait raisonnable en fait
de mettre une aide active à mourir avant
que les soins palliatifs soient
suffisamment développés alors
vous dites qu'on avance sur les deux sur
nos deux jambes ils ont l'air plutôt de
mettre une forme de chronologie
développer les soins palliatifs pour
être sûr moi ce qui me dérangerait par
exemple c'est que l'aide active à mourir
soit une forme de d'un pas de forme
imparfaite de soins palliatifs je pense
qu'il est aujourd'hui important vraiment
de de pouvoir soigner et calmer les
douleurs et c'est encore pas partout
possible le domicile vous l'avez dit les
fins de vie à domicile peuvent être
vécus d'une manière enfin encore
aujourd'hui sur certains territoires de
manière très difficile le retour à
domicile les gens veulent mourir à
domicile mais les deux derniers jours
ils retournent très souvent à l'hôpital
parce que y compris pour l'entourage
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué de
trouver effectivement des professionnels
de santé et des professionnels de santé
formés à l'accompagnement soins
palliatifs les infirmières ça panique
quelquefois et il y a le retour à
l'hôpital dans des situations
effectivement difficiles donc il y a un
sujet de formation et peut-être la
question cruciale c'est le nombre de
soignants quoi comment enfin si vous
avez un peu je pense qu'il y a un plan
parce qu'il y a un plan décennale quel
est financièrement comment ça va se
budgétiser et comment la formation des
soignants on va pouvoir être au
rendez-vous pour pouvoir accompagner en
fait cette fin de vie cette fin de vie
de soins pâle donc c'est plutôt sur les
soins palliatifs
on va rajouter Bernard bonne qu'elle
avait la main j'étais Bernard
très rapidement alors j'essaye je
voudrais d'abord savoir la différence
entre l'aide d'Activa mourir et de
suicider
à quelle différence on fait dans dans
ces deux termes et puis deux ou trois
questions quand vous parlez du moyen
terme à 6 mois le moyen terme à 6 mois
je sais pas pour des médecins c'est
difficile de dire dans les six mois vous
allez mourir donc on ne peut jamais
savoir ce moyen terme ce qu'il serait
exactement on a parlé aussi de de
l'évaluation qui n'a pas été faite dans
les saints palliatifs et tout à l'heure
elle a mis en disait on passe d'une loi
l'autre à une troisième loi sans avoir
du tout évalué ni la première ni la
deuxième est-ce que c'est pas
intéressant quand même de faire une
évaluation claire de la loi c'est clair
de la loi classe lyonneti avant
peut-être de mettre en place c'est ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure qui avait
pas eu d'évaluation nette de justement
de modification de cette loi tester
Unity et puis une autre question la
directive anticipée la directive
anticipée on parle de la directive
anticipée mais imaginons que de tous
puisque vous le demandiez en face une
directive anticipée on va tous dire moi
si jamais je ne viens Alzheimer j'ai
envie tout de suite de comme face à
suicide assisté ou une dative à mourir
mais à partir de quel moment on le fait
si on a plus de discernement mais qu'on
a mis en place une directive anticipée à
partir de quand moi j'ai vu des
personnes dans ma pratique ou dans dans
ma famille qui ont mis enfin qui ont mis
c'est difficile à dire mais plusieurs
années avant de mourir est-ce qu'on les
tue toutes enfin ce qu'on les assiste
tout de suite ou est-ce qu'on attend un
an deux ans trois ans quatre ans cinq
ans six ans donc là aussi ça sera
difficile à définir et puis la dernière
chose vous avez dit tout à l'heure en
début de
en début d'audition le président a
décidé qu'il fallait mettre en place une
loi pour l'aide active à mourir
mais s'il Parlement est contre on va pas
mettre cette loi en application je pense
que le Parlement aura quand même la
possibilité même si le président a très
envie de que cette loi soit mise en
place rapidement je pense que le
Parlement gardera quand même la maîtrise
du de l'acceptation ou pas de cette loi
je l'espère en tout cas avant avant
mes réflexions et vous me direz ce que
vous en pensez alors Monsieur sénateur
je pense que vous avez fait un raccourci
de mes propos j'ai dit que le Président
de la République est celui que nous
travaillons la construction d'un projet
de loi je vous ai aussi dit que le débat
devait avoir lieu et que peu importe
donc pas de raccourcis et pas de de de
de voilà de propos le 3 avril le
président de la République a souhaité
que nous travaillons à la construction
d'un projet de loi qui sera présenté
avant la fin de l'été voilà donc voilà
les lois connaissent le Lydie a été
évaluée elle a été évaluée justement
nous avons souhaité ouvrir tous les
champs l'évaluation de la loi classe le
midi elle a eu lieu elle a eu lieu elle
a été faite par la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale et le rapport fait par
l'évaluation par les affaires par la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale montre à quel
point la loi classe ne répond pas à
toutes les situations même avis que le
que le CCNE
directive anticipé et aide active à
mourir faut pallier les deux si Vincent
Lambert avait redirigé ses directives
anticipées il y aurait pas eu d'affaires
Vincent Lambert
si Vincent Lambert avait rédigé ses
directives anticipées donc par contre
par contre on peut bah oui non mais
c'est juste je me permets de répondre à
votre question précisément faut pas lier
l'aide d'active à mourir et les
directeurs motivés par contre puisque je
viens un échange assez intéressant avec
jean-lucci et ce sujet l'idée c'est de
se dire aussi est-ce qu'on a 20 ans je
pense qu'il est important de d'expliquer
qu'il est important de rédiger ses
directeurs anticipées on nous annonce
une maladie incurable on peut réfléchir
à des directives accompagnées c'est tout
à fait autre chose et c'est un autre
process et j'en ai eu dit n'est pas
fermé à ce qu'on nous puissions
réfléchir à ces deux types de directives
qui sont totalement différentes et là je
réponds à votre question l'État qui va
mourir c'est pas les dative à mourir
c'est euthanasie ou suicide assisté
c'est c'est la définition générique
c'est pas la méthode choisie
ça peut être l'un ou l'autre
ça peut être l'un ou l'autre ou les deux
d'ailleurs les pays les pays qui ont
légiféré sur les deux c'est le cas de la
Belgique mais 99%
c'est l'euthanasie alors que la Belgique
a légiférée sur les deux voilà
la définition du moyen terme c'est bien
c'est bien le sujet c'est bien la
difficulté mais je vous rappelle que la
loi classe Leity c'est la sédation
profonde et continue pour un pronostic
vital engagé à très court terme là aussi
la question du très court terme elle est
elle se pose elle se pose ah bah
peut-être un peu moins mais elle se pose
quand même
mais c'est pour ça je vous dis que
c'était intéressant d'aller voir dans
les pays qui ont légiféré sur le
pronostic vital engagé à moyen terme ou
l'Orégon se pose des questions
les médecins se posent des questions ils
sont partis sur six mois et se posent
des questions de savoir si c'est neuf
mois ou 12 mois voilà c'est des
questions sur lequel
pour allonger pour allonger le
voilà après sur les soins palliatifs je
le redis et c'est pour répondre à vous
madame Guillotin je le redis moi je
pense qu'il est important et je ne vais
pas préjugé des travaux qui seront les
nôtres de proposer dans l'accès dans une
personne qui serait éligible aux
différents
de passer par les soins je pense que
c'est pour moi quelque chose de
nécessaire je le redis parce que on peut
aussi pendant cette période là changer
d'avis ou pas mais je pense qu'il est
important de pouvoir le proposer il est
important de pouvoir le proposer
donc la loi classique elle a bien été
évaluée et Monsieur Milon pour essayer
de répondre à votre question pourquoi
s'engager maintenant
dans ce process d'abord le CCNE a émis
un avis je le dis le c'était important
de se caler sur l'avis du CCNE que la
société a évolué aussi pendant cette
période elle a évolué plutôt assez
rapidement
et plutôt de façon à évaluer assez
rapidement avec
une proposition en pourcentage assez
constant de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent que la loi évolue ça veut pas
dire que 75% de nos concitoyens
souhaitent un jour
pouvoir bénéficier de d'une aide active
à mourir je ne suis pas sûr parce que
c'est une question de bien portant qu'on
est en train de se poser je ne suis pas
sûr qu'au moment
voilà donc voilà c'est c'est important
de se dire la question l'idée c'est de
pas ouvrir cette aide et ses dérives
comme on peut le voir dans au Canada
enfin je le redis il y aura bien des
critères d'éligibilité mais c'est
d'ouvrir ce nouveau droit dans certaines
situations et je le redis de travailler
sur sur les 100 vallées et pour répondre
à votre question parce que ça
sous-entendait la question sur les
médecins nous travaillons depuis le mois
de septembre avec les médecins avec un
groupe de soignants pas que des médecins
nous avons aussi souhaité associer des
infirmières des aides-soignantes
des médecins qui sont favorables des
médecins qui ne sont pas favorables à
l'évolution de la loi je pense que
travailler travailler avec les médecins
sur ces réflexions les parlementaires
qui se sont engagés à de nos côtés ont
travaillé aussi avec les médecins
et nous continuons nous avons réuni hier
matin
les soignants qui ont commencé à
réfléchir et à émettre j'allais dire des
positions puisque maintenant on est dans
la construction de la loi nous donner
des avis techniques
je vais pas je vais pas vous cacher que
la clause de conscience spécifique et
pour moi quelque chose en postulat de
base enfin je ne vois pas comment c'est
quelque chose d'important enfin je et je
crois pas que grand monde s'oppose à ça
je crois pas que grand monde s'oppose à
ça c'est ça me paraît ça me paraît parce
que de toute façon j'allais dire peu
importe peu importe le modèle la
modalité choisie pour l'aide active à
mourir
il y a bien une personne qui est capable
de dire que le pronostic vital est
engagé c'est bien le médecin c'est bien
médecin donc le médecin interviendra
forcément
au début du process si nous choisissons
d'autres si nous choisissons
le Suisse à Disney pas mais il
interviendra le seul personne capable de
dire que le pronostic vital est engagé
c'est le médecin c'est le médecin qui
fait le diagnostic voilà je crois que
j'ai répondu à peu près tout
décision sur la mission la formation
c'est c'est l'évidence c'est pour ça
qu'on part sur une stratégie décennale
c'est pour ça qu'on dit en faut former
les professionnels j'ai rencontré les
professionnels du secteur du
médico-social pour savoir comment on
peut former aussi les infirmières en
EHPAD à l'enjeu bien sûr
parce que c'est important aussi je le
redis l'intervention du domicile de
pouvoir faire des équipes mobiles de
soins palliatifs qui interviennent dans
les épargnes parce que les
professionnels auront été formés et
qu'il y aura et qu'il y aurait dans les
EHPAD une infirmière au lieu d'un
domicile en mesure d'accompagner les
résistants les résidents jusqu'au bout
dans leur domicile dans leur domicile et
pas se retrouver aux
urgences
c'est voilà donc c'est tout ça qu'on est
en train de construire
ça me semble important et nécessaire
un point de précision très court
en Corrèze on a des lits identifiés
soins palliatif on n'a pas d'unité de
son palliatifs pourtant ça marche très
bien et notamment on n'est pas des à
domicile alors il faudrait sûrement les
renforcer parce que des fois on vient de
le dire Véronique on est obligé
d'hospitaliser les gens mais dans la
très grande majorité des gens à domicile
et on n'a pas de soins palliatifs on a
c'est ce qui avait été dit j'ai entendu
ça
à la radio par des personnes qui sont
pour
mourir donc par
pour pour l'aide actif à mourir qui
avait pas de sympa natif encore être
effectivement il y en a pas d'unité de
son palliatifs mais il y a bien des lits
identifiez loin de soins palliatifs dans
les trois hôpitaux et on peut demander à
l'équipe de venir en EHPAD et à domicile
ça fonctionne donc c'est ça qu'il faut
renforcer
moi je m'interroge sur les maladies
incurables
parce que de toute évidence bon comme
Daniel chassa je suis un vieux médecin
et quand on faisait nos études de
médecine le cancer était une maladie
incurable elle ne l'est plus maintenant
pratiquement plus maintenant il y a
d'autres maladies en particulier les
maladies de l'enfant les cancers de
l'enfant qui étaient considérés comme
des maladies complètement incurables et
qui ne le sont plus maintenant parce que
on a fait peut-être un peu d'acharnement
thérapeutique on a cherché des
traitements nouveaux et on a trouvé des
traitements efficaces donc est-ce que le
fait de diagnostiquer une maladie
incurable et puis de dire dans ces
conditions vous avez droit à aller
jusqu'à choisir votre mort et être aidé
pour mourir on ne va pas empêcher la
recherche de trouver des traitements
efficaces par la suite
Imbert et Christine bonfantie très court
parce que si on refait le truc
chez nous mais le sujet est tellement
passionnant je reviens sur la convention
citoyenne madame la ministre il y a une
partie de la convention qui envisage le
tanasie qui pourrait être demandé par la
personne de confiance je parle pas des
directives anticipées mais il y a une
personne de confiance désignée et la
conscience citoyenne dit enfin une
partie
l'euthanasie pourrait demander par la
personne de confiance ça veut dire que
la mort pour être donnée à une personne
qui va ne demande pas
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
proposition de la convention s'il vous
plaît
il semble que Olivier Véran penche
plutôt pour le tanasie que vous vous
soyez plus vers le suicide assisté et
que le ministre de la Santé a dit de ta
nazis ce n'est pas un souhait est-ce que
vous êtes sûr que vous allez pouvoir
élaborer un projet de loi
on va forcément élaborer un projet de
loi je le rappelle que c'est l'objet de
la mission qu'il a notre sur ce sujet là
je le redis sur un sujet qui touche à
l'intime chacun
et ici je ne sais pas ce que pensent les
uns et les autres le projet de la
République le président de la République
nous a demandé d'établir un projet de
loi c'est ce vers quoi nous travaillons
je le dis moi je ne vais pas préjugé des
travaux qui sont les nôtres et est-ce
qu'on va vers le tanazi vers le suicide
assisté l'important c'est qu'on arrive à
rendre ce nouveau droit effectivement
mais vous me taquiner mais je vous
réponds de la même façon
dans le gouvernement je ne sais pas vous
répondre qui pense quoi c'est pas
l'objet c'est pas l'objet du débat on a
la mission de construire un projet de
loi et c'est ce vers quoi nous allons
nous allons travailler pour répondre sur
les enjeux de la recherche heureusement
notre recherche a avancé et ce pourquoi
nous évacuons les mineurs
de la discussion entre guillemets et ce
pourquoi nous allons vers les soins
palliatifs pour les mineurs c'est que il
y a 10 ans 80% des enfants atteints d'un
cancer pédiatrique décédés aujourd'hui
80% guérissent donc la loi la loi la
recherche a beaucoup avancé sur la prise
en charge il faut s'en féliciter et donc
il faut continuer à travailler sur les
nouvelles maladies qui sont découvertes
mais en attendant je reviens sur le
sujet de la maladie de Charcot qui est
je la nomme volontairement parce que
c'est celle qui nous est
régulièrement faut continuer la
recherche il faut l'accélérer la
recherche sur la maladie de Charcot et
j'espère qu'on va réussir à trouver
quelque chose qui nous permette de
prendre en charge la maladie de Charcot
pour l'instant il y a rien qui nous
permet de prendre en charge la vallée de
Charcot et donc
la question c'est est-ce que on avance
pas dans la loi pour permettre avec les
critères d'agilité à ces personnes si
elles le souhaitent pas leur mettre leur
demander de le faire si elle le souhaite
j'aurais bien que c'est c'est un choix
c'est un choix c'est pas une obligation
c'est un choix de pouvoir à la place
d'aller en Suisse ou en Belgique parce
que n'oublions pas que nous avons
certains nombre de comptes citoyens qui
aujourd'hui vont en Belgique ou en
Suisse
c'est ça la question ça rend nos
concitoyens vont en Belgique ou en
Suisse voilà donc
la question la question opposée par vous
madame la sénatrice Imbert c'est l'enjeu
de cérébrolysie qui est une vraie
question
la question du discernement elle a été
très clairement posée par par le
Président de la République très
clairement posé par les membres de la
Convention citoyenne reste la question
des personnes cérébralisées pour
laquelle j'ai pas de réponse là tout de
suite de chic sur ce que nous
soufflerons et ce que la loi proposera
mais c'est un vrai enjeu moi ce que je
voudrais dire en conclusion en tout cas
de mes réponses c'est que il y a
quelques la société évolue mais la codh
a rendu en octobre un avis assez
différent des avis et donc évolue aussi
dans les avis qu'elle rend la cour
modifie radicalement le fondement en
auto logique de la convention qui
d'universelle devient individuel
voilà je voulais juste te dire ça
moi de réflexion 3
la première
c'est que sur cette notion de maladie de
Charcot je vous le dis parce que ça nous
a été dit en audition un médecin une
société savante de Somme palliatifs
trouvaient que à chaque fois de remettre
le nom de on va faire quelque chose
quand même pour les maladies de Charcot
non mais je le dis tel que on nous l'a
dit
certains patients atteints de maladie de
Charcot
ne le vivait pas très bien voilà une
fois que j'ai dit ça c'est pas forcément
une c'est une observation ce n'est pas
une question la deuxième c'est on dit
souvent la loi naiti n'est pas
suffisante moi souvent je le dis et je
l'ai dit si souvent cette commission
certes néanmoins le texte qui nous est
préparé sur lequel chacun s'exprimera
son âme et conscience avec en effet la
difficulté d'avoir des certitudes
ce texte à mon sens c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait différent de cette loi
kless leonétique qui sont pour des gens
qui vont mourir à très court terme et
qui sont là sur des gens qui qui veulent
mourir je pense que on est sur un autre
principe que celui d'ouvrir un nouveau
droit à mon sens c'est quand même un
texte tout à fait différent et le
troisième point c'est on cite beaucoup
et qu'on Sponville l'avait dit quand on
a auditionné
oui mais quand même les gens très âgés
oui mais quand même les gens coin grand
handicap oui mais quand même les gens
qui ont de maladies très graves ben cela
quand même peut-être on pourrait moi je
trouve que dans une société où on parle
beaucoup des vulnérabilités beaucoup de
personnes en grande difficulté en grande
vulnérabilité en grande les mettre un
peu dans ces catégories où on finit par
leur dire peut-être quand même tu as une
solution qui pourrait quand même
arranger bien des choses je trouve ça
une forme et je le dis comme je l'ai dit
hier à la ferme une forme de
décibilisation pour reprendre le mot du
président de la République
alors permettez-moi de vous reprendre de
vous répondre vraiment très franchement
sur ce sujet est-ce que dans mes propos
à aucun non mais non mais je dis non
mais je dis non mais je voulais c'est
pour l'esprit c'est pour l'esprit c'est
pour l'esprit je veux dire que notre
rôle
est notre pacte républicain
doit nous amener à prendre en charge
toutes les vulnérabilités et vous parlez
de décibilisation moi je dis à toutes
ces personnes qui imaginent que si nous
travaillons sur ce pourquoi j'ai de loin
c'est pour permettre à ces personnes de
demander ce droit moi je le considère
comme une outrance
et je répondrai de façon j'allais dire
à des civilisations je répondrai
outrance notre devoir notre pacte
républicain qui repose sur les
solidarités c'est bien d'accompagner
toutes les formes de vulnérabilité que
ce soit les personnes en situation de
handicap que ce soit les personnes âgées
d'où la nécessité d'avoir des critères
d'éligibilité et d'accès qui soit
j'allais dire pour le coup très clair et
très précis dans la loi je le redis moi
je ne me sens pas en mesure de porter un
projet de loi comme celui-là et si tel
était le cas je ne le porterai pas je le
dis vraiment très sincèrement et ça
n'est pas la volonté ni du président de
la République ni de la première ministre
de faire de notre société une société
qui permettrait aux personnes en
situation de handicap et aux personnes
âgées de pouvoir non c'est pas c'est pas
notre société c'est pas notre pacte
républicain vraiment je le redis
vraiment très sincèrement
[Musique]
sur la maladie de Charcot il s'agit pas
de stigmatiser ni une maladie d'ailleurs
on le dit parce que c'est une maladie
dont on parle beaucoup plus et c'est
c'est la maladie pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas de réponse thérapeutique
pour laquelle nous avons le plus de
sollicitations de la part de nos
concitoyens sur comment peut-on faire
puisque la loi classe Leity nous répond
pas à cette problématique là aux
personnes qui le demandent c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée donc il
s'agit pas de stigmatiser une maladie il
faut continuer la recherche comme l'a
dit le sénateur Milan faut vraiment que
nous arrivions et que nous continuons la
recherche pour trouver une réponse à
cette maladie là d'ailleurs je ne pense
pas que la loi devra nommer la maladie
de Charcot il faudra travailler
sur le non mais je le dis on le dit dans
nos
bien sûr bien sûr mais mais faut
vraiment faut vraiment que on mais c'est
ce qui nous amène à réfléchir et à
évoluer
c'est bien tous ces malades qui nous
posent les questions et d'ailleurs
ce sont ceux qui s'expriment en ce
moment le plus dans les médias ce sont
les malades atteints de la vallée
Charcot certains disent moi je souhaite
profiter de chaque jour pour continuer à
vivre
et d'autres disent moi j'ai déjà préparé
mon départ en Suisse donc on est bien
sur la volonté exprimée par ces malades
d'avoir le choix ou pas et face à la
maladie je crois que chacun ne sait pas
comment il réagira là on se pose des
questions parce qu'on est bien portant
voilà et ce que je tiens à dire aussi
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais
que c'est l'ouverture de ce débat c'est
aussi une ouverture enfin c'est aussi la
le rapport à la mort qui nous est
questionné c'est un sujet sur lequel
c'est un sujet difficile dont on parle
peu et donc on a très peu parlé de
l'accompagnement du deuil qui est pour
moi aussi un enjeu majeur sur lequel
nous souhaitons aussi dans le cadre de
cette réflexion pouvoir avancer parce
que c'est le troisième pilier tout à
l'heure je parlais de directives
anticipée
mais je pense que l'accompagnement du
deuil c'est aussi quelque chose et la
question qui nous pose aussi sur lequel
faut avancer c'est retenir ce qui nous
est arrivé pendant la crise sanitaire
certains n'ont cit sont décédés tout
seul en EHPAD à l'hôpital donc la
réflexion sur un droit opposable
la création d'un endroit opposable à la
visite dans ces situations là se pose
voilà donc c'est aussi tous ces tous ces
sujets là sur lequel on va essayer de
travailler mais vraiment
l'accompagnement du deuil notre rapport
à la mort sont très questionnés à
travers l'ouverture de ce débat il faut
en profiter parce qu'on n'a pas toujours
l'occasion de discuter de ces sujets qui
sont notre parcours de vie un jour on
est un jour on meurt
bien voilà donc c'est une préfiguration
de débat intéressant
que nous que nous aurons je pense à
l'automne et merci Madame la Ministre
cet échange franc et clair